avec nos invités anton un pêcheur avocat
au barreau de paris et michel ascaron
chi ancien député européen messieurs
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
en tonneau peschard en tant qu'avocat
comment appréciez-vous l'avis du conseil
constitutionnel on rappelle qui avait
légué l'essentiel de la loi sanitaire
ce qui est ce qu'il faut savoir pour
être tout à fait clair par rapport au
conseil constitutionnel c'est que c'est
une juridiction on n'est même pas sûr
d'un point de vue juridique ce qu'une
juridiction mais disons que c'est une
juridiction qui va prendre sa décision
en mettant en balance des impératifs
l'impératif de protection des libertés
individuelles et en face duquel on va
faire peser les impératifs de sécurité
le conseil constitutionnel
peut juger de manière très politique on
décide en assez subjective manqué
l'impératif prévaut sur quel autre
impératif ça fait des années que le
conseil constitutionnel se prononce et
s'assure esprit danse assez constante
pour faire imprimer l'impératif de
sécurité on l'a vu il ya plusieurs
années avec les lois sur l'état
d'urgence terroristes et en nous
aujourd'hui avec l'état d'urgence
sanitaire c'est une décision qui
appartient aux membres qui l'ont
prononcé avec laquelle on peut tout à
fait ne pas être d'accord puisque avec
les mêmes impératifs on aurait pu rendre
une décision tout à fait contraire d'un
point de vue plus précis je pense que
pour prendre l'exemple le plus le plus
significatif c'est l'harmonisation de
l'article 9 par rapport au droit du
travail en empêchant
l'application de cet article conseil
constitutionnel a potentiellement rendu
là des situations bien pires pour les
salariés puisque en fait si vous êtes
absent plusieurs mois pour défaut de
passes sanitaires et votre société n'a
pas les moyens de vous remplacer un
autre poste vous pouvez être licencié à
ce moment là pour
désorganisation des services donc en
réalité le conseil constitutionnel a
rendu des services à la personne et
s'est prononcée encore une fois pour un
état sécuritaire plutôt pour un état
libéral qui est l'adn de la france mais
c'est la sq a renoncé se passa sanitaire
aurait-il été plus acceptable en par
ceux qui s'y opposent s'il y avait eu
plus de concertation
mais écoutez il ya eu concertation vous
êtes dans un pays dans une démocratie la
démocratie c'est quoi c'est le fait que
le parlement soit saisi le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale donc nos deux
parlements et que le conseil
constitutionnel valide leur décision ou
ne valide pas d'ailleurs tout cela a été
fait en respect du droit donc quand
j'entends parler de d'atteintes aux
libertés de dictature et c'est à vous
demander dans quel pays vous êtes un
mois j'ai combattu à 24 ans les
dictatures sud-américaines peux vous
dire que si nous étions en dictature il
n'y aurait pas de manifestation il n'y
aurait pas de vote il n'y aurait pas
d'expression donc il faut remettre les
choses à leur place il faut arrêter avec
ces cette surenchère de bêtises un
dictature apartheid antisémitisme il
faut arrêter ou sommes nous nous sommes
dans une démocratie nous sommes dans une
république
les autorités l'état et le président au
premier chef ont pris des décisions pour
protéger la santé des français si des
gens veulent pas se faire vacciner c'est
leur problème s'il accepte le risque
d'être hospitalisée de mourir c'est leur
problème le problème c'est que la
liberté c'est pas la liberté pour soi
seulement la liberté c'est la liberté
aussi pour autrui est donc au nom de
quoi des gens quand ils le droit de ne
pas se faire vacciner de mettre en
danger la vie de leurs concitoyens
vivre en société c'est respecter les
autres donc je constate que les pas
vaccinés ou les anti-pacs sanitaire le
bas sanitaire c'est ce qui nous permet
de vivre librement de belles confiné un
dock il ya qu'à voir ce qui se passe aux
antilles en guadeloupe à la réunion ou
en polynésie il dit est ce que ces
images là ne suffisent pas voilà la
situation dans laquelle nous pourrions
être à pas et dans notre nom notre
métropole 6 s'il n'y avait pas le pass
and i ter en seraient confinés donc il
ya des gens qui manifestent parce qu'ils
préfèrent être enfermé plutôt qu'être
dehors c'est leur problème moi je
constate qu'aujourd'hui il ya deux cent
cinquante mille même s'ils sont 300 me
peu importe manifestants je je je je
prends noble que ça s'est bien passé ce
qui est déjà le plus important pour les
manifestations trois cent mille
personnes qu'est ce que c'est par
rapport aux quatre cent mille français
qui ont été vaccinées hier et aux quatre
cent mille français quand tu es vacciner
aujourd'hui samedi c'est rien qu'est ce
que c'est par pur 67 millions de
français ce n'est rien fall avoir
l'esprit c'est du ce et du tapage du
tapage médiatique
entraînés par un leader des défilés
jaune en mal de notoriété et par un
filippo qui se dit patriote alors qu'il
est le premier collaborateur le premier
collabos du virus il est le premier
collabos du duduk ovide 19 puisqu'il est
complice de kovy 19 en décidant d'être
contre la vaccination contre le pass
annie terre sans le pass annie termes
monsieur philippe on n'aurait pas dû
aller en italie manifester contre les
italiens ont mis en place comme en
france comme les grecs comme les danois
comme nez comme les hollandais comme les
belges et cetera je constate moi que le
pass annie terre maintenant est la règle
générale dans toute l'europe donc nous
sommes dans toute l'europe dans des
dictatures nous sommes dans toute
l'europe dans des pays d'apartheid
arrêtons arrêtons arrêtons les vrais
débats se sont pas cela est vrai débat
c'est comment on arrête cette pandémie
cette pandémie a fait aujourd'hui 5
millions de morts dans le monde et est
elle est en france plus de 130000 s'il
n'y avait pas le vaccin nous allons vers
des centaines de millions de mort s'il
n'ya pas le vaccin pourquoi parce que le
delta tu es et si on n'arrête pas le
delta il y aura un invariant encore plus
puissants et de 2,2 variant destructeur
multiplier un vous allez arriver à quoi
vous allez arriver à une pandémie
mondiale qui va faire des centaines de
millions de morts alors arrêtons ces y'a
que le vaccin pour arrêter la pandémie
et il n'y a que le pass anitea pour nous
permet de vivre en liberté même si cette
liberté je le conçois je le conseille
est encadré mais il vaut mieux ça que
d'être offert mais voyons monsieur scar
bon c'est merci anton à empêcheurs vous
voyez lever
les sourcils est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à répondre à monsieur
oscar bauchi oui je remercie de me
laisser l'opportunité de répondre
alors de manière générale vous
vous avez un discours assez colérique et
haineux envers des gens qui justement
marche pour des questions de liberté
vous nous expliquer que on va vers des
centaines de millions de morts je pense
que quand on prend les chiffres des
décès et les pronostics vitaux engagé
les chiffres officiels je parle après
les vaccinations je pense qu'on a aussi
la liberté de ne pas prendre le risque
de mourir après avoir pris un médicament
c'est chasser la première réponse que je
voudrais vous apportez que vous essayez
vous ai laissé finir monsieur vous allez
me laisser terminer que vous et que vous
essayez converture en amérique du sud
chf ou tire mon chapeau et je pense que
c'est le rêve de beaucoup de jeunes de
pouvoir se battre pour des questions
politiques
et c'est aussi une éducation et celle là
dessus je suis d'accord j'ai écouté
votre intérieur à 4 - vous avez
parfaitement raison on est dans un monde
où les gens cherchent leur revanche ils
sont habitués alors au fort il nous a pu
se battre parce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui monsieur permettez moi de
vous dire que justement c'est tout le
contraire du discours que vous tenez il
ya quatre mois puisque les gens qui se
battent aujourd'hui pour des questions
de libertés sont ceux qui sont dans la
rue les personnes qui ont voulu chercher
leur confort aux pris le risque après 2
juillet pour avoir des témoignages par
centaines de proches se sont fait
vacciner simplement pour pouvoir aller
au restaurant vous nous dites que aussi
que le pass sanitaire c'est vivre
librement excusez moi mais j'ai pas du
tout la même approche que vous et je
pense que beaucoup de français puisque
beaucoup de français vaccinés également
retrouve dans les manifestations n'ont
pas du tout ce point de vue le bassin
sanitaire c'est le contraire de la
berthe et de toute façon ils vous serez
je pense d'accord avec moi vers quoi on
tend c'est une question de calendrier
politique vers une vaccination au
pleinement obligatoires et vous qui avez
résisté en amérique du sud de monsieur
pour en terminer sur maria conso vous
qui avez milité ans qui avait combattu
en amérique du sud fournil dit
qu'aujourd'hui quatre cent mille
personnes ce sont des vaccinés hier
contre eux peut-être 300 milles dans la
rue alors permettez moi de mettre en
doute les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur marocain contre chiffres et
tout le monde pense les chiffres
officiels mais pour avoir manifesté je
pense qu'on est beaucoup plus nombreux
que ce que veut bien dire le ministère
de l'intérieur mais monsieur vous qui
avez combattu en amérique du sud est-ce
que c'était la majorité qui ce qui a
combattu est ce que pendant la
résistance est loin de moi l'idée de
faire des parallèles avec la deuxième
guerre mondiale et les katas trois qui
sont arrivés mais pour prendre un
exemple de résistance ou plusieurs
éléments de résistance combien sont les
résistants espèces il pas eu qui ont
permis à l'abbaye de se relever de
dictature alors évidemment dernière en
master l'instant nous ne sommes pas en
dictature aujourd'hui néanmoins et
malgré ne fais que la procédure
législative a été suivi avec 350 députés
godillots qui votent les yeux fermés le
dernier mois et a été donnée à
l'assemblée nationale puisqu'il ya quand
même eu une commission paritaire qui
s'est rassemblée bon preuve que les deux
chambres ne sont pas d'accord donc un
désaccord politique profond en france à
au sujet du pass sanitaires c'est ce
n'est pas les majorités qui ont rendu
leur liberté à les pays et moi je
préfère faire confiance à ses deux cent
cinquante mille personnes qui prennent
qui demandent la liberté de ne pas se
faire tuer en prenant l'accent sur
lequel on n'a pas de recul puisque c'est
là 160 morts et 2500 pronostics vitaux
engagé en six mois sur un an celle des
vaccins en france le faiza pour le
nommez moi c'est cette minorité qui
parle qui qui pour moi
protègent les libertés les français
savent qu'à renoncer je vais peut-être
vous vous laissez répond on est pressé
par le temps et vous demandez s'il vous
plaît des trois rapide de huy cette
crise en fait que nous vivons un par
rapport à cette pandémie n est que le
reflet d'une d'une crise de la
démocratie c'est à dire nous sommes en
règle générale dans la démocratie si
c'est la majorité la règle générale
c'est la majorité or depuis en gros le
quinquennat de françois hollande nous
vivons avec la loi des minorités c'est à
dire qu'il suffit que des gens
manifestent dans la rue alors on a connu
ça avec les gilets jaunes mais c'était
une crise sociale maintenant connais ça
avec les anti-pacs cd anti vaccins c'est
une crise sanitaire voilà mais ce sont
ceux sont ces minorités qui défie alors
quand tu es des films paisiblement tout
va bien mais quand on s'attaque à des
pharmacies
quand on menace de mort des gens parce
qu'ils ont un discours pour le vaccin
moi je choisis la science je ne choisis
pas les tartuffes je choisis la science
et le progrès monsieur parce que c'est
ce qui fait du magny t et tout le reste
ça ne conduit qu'à des cas des dérapages
cas des cadets florian philippot des
dupont d'aignan des professeurs du vin
etc c'est à dire des tartuffes cola
points messieurs merci en tout cas on
n'avait pour l'instant des
manifestations qui se sont très bien
déroulées avec des profils très
différents dans les manifestants quand
on appelle ça vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris merci à vous d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
michel oscars dont fives l'ancien député
européen merci à tous les deux messieurs
d'avoir épousé en studio